dit et puis le dernier jour la politique
avec d'abord aujourd'hui l'annoncé par
monsieur georges marchais lui-même qu'il
serait de nouveau candidat au poste de
secrétaire général du parti communiste
français à l'occasion du prochain 24e
congrès monsieur marchait interrogé par
la radio canadienne a également indiqué
qu'ils pensaient que ce prochain congrès
confirmerait la ligne politique définie
lors des deux précédents congrès
politique encore avec le discours
prononcé cet après midi par monsieur
roland leroy le reportage de jean michel
mercure temps forts de cette fête de
l'humanité le discours de roland leroy
était d'abord l'occasion de saluer la
présence de ministres communistes pour
la troisième fois seulement dans
l'histoire du parti devant une assemblée
nombreuse et avant la pluie
roland leroy a développé le thème d'un
parti de combat dans un pays qui subit
encore la pression du patronat contre le
changement
l'heure n'est pas à la satisfaction
confiante expliqué roland leroy
car les conséquences de la politique du
grand capital se prolonge au-delà de son
rennes est dans le camp de ceux qui
empêchent encore le changement ou qu'ils
vont pas assez loin
roland leroy de citer pêle-mêle le cnpf
les partis de droite les médias radio
télé et même certains journaux de gauche
pas de surenchère tout ne peut pas être
fait en un jour mais les communistes ne
renonceront pas à leur proposition même
si le pays n'en a pas voulu entièrement
et tout de suite non les communistes ne
se sont pas renier et roland leroy a
longuement cité le candidat georges
marchais pendant sa campagne
chaque changement même partiel est une
condition meilleur pour progresser les
communistes pour toujours ce qu'ils
disent a conclu roland leroy et ils se
doivent d'être les artisans d'une
politique nouvelle dans la nouvelle
majorité pour aller de l'avant
pour répondre aux espérances qui se sont
levés
les communistes participe au
gouvernement de la france
ils ne sont pas pour autant partie du
gouvernement lui avocat inconditionnels
de celui ci ni partisans assurent au
cheikh où la démagogie c'est le flou sur
tous les chantiers du changement que
expriment leurs contributions originales
et irremplaçable à l'oeuvre engagée
c'est en étant pleinement de même c'est
parce que ils sont et restent pleinement
de même que les communistes entendent
tout faire pour réussir
c'est une garantie c'est un atout pour
les travailleurs et pour la france
vous le voyez plus que jamais le peuple
de france a besoin d'un parti communiste
plus fort
sans nous il n'y aurait pas eu hier deux
victoires électorales sans nous il n'y
aurait pas demain de politiques
nouvelles
monsieur lionel jospin lui le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste était
l'invité du club de la presse ce soir de
notre confrère europe numéro 1 au
lendemain de la réunion du comité
directeur de son parti qui a finalement
décidé de se présenter unie au prochain
congrès de valence toutes tendances
confondues du moins pour le moment
alors monsieur jospin répond à une
question sur les relations justement
avec le pc des relations pour l'instant
au beau fixe selon lui monsieur jeunes
en moi je pense que les ministres
communistes actuellement chaude ministre
qui applique là les décisions
collectives du gouvernement et qui
respecte la solidarité gouvernementale
quant à ce que je lis dans l'humanité
aux déclarations de georges marchais qui
disait je crois en gros que ce que nous
avions fait à l'est mais qui formulaient
un certain nombre de critiques sur un
certain nombre de points
je les trouve personnellement plutôt
satisfaisante devraient pas donner
l'impression que je fais partie d'une
association des premiers secrétaires ou
secrétaires généraux de partie mais je
trouve quand même assez normal que
georges marchais puisse s'exprimer
voudriez quand même pas qu'il
disparaisse de la vie politique que
seuls les quatre ministres communistes
et le droit de parler maintenant
alors il va s'exprimer j'imagine et une
est normal qu'ils formulent un certain
nombre de critiques
ce qui m'importe c'est de savoir si ces
critiques restent limitées si elle
représente ce que pense le parti
communiste et qu'elle ne touche pas à
l'essentiel à ce qui est décisif à
savoir l'action en commun mené au
gouvernement jeu démocratique doit pas
s'arrêter parce qu'il ya un gouvernement
d'union - alors pour monsieur jospin il
a tenu à le réaffirmer il ne faut pas
identifié le gouvernement et le parti
socialiste
à l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique
le front national de monsieur jean-marie
le pen étaient réunis aujourd'hui dans
la vallée de chevreuse
un reportage de lucie soboul ils étaient
un millier cet après-midi réunis pour la
fête du front national venu ici pour la
fête avec les stands et les chanteurs
mais surtout pour la rentrée politique
de jean-marie le pen
résident du front national jean marie le
pen qui a critiqué la politique du
gouvernement
pour lui le fait marquant de cette
rentrée c'est que la révolution marxiste
est en marche
mes pensées semble plongée dans le
sommeil
on croirait à regarder le pays et les
statistiques et les sondages il ne s'est
pas rendu compte de ce qui s'était passé
et pourtant quel chemin parcouru sous
l'égide de l'état de grâce
en quatre mois le socialisme et son
allié le communisme sont en train de
mettre en place une phase d'accélération
de la décadence et de l' esclavage de
notre pays à l'étranger les dernières
manoeuvres de l'armée soviétique mettant
en branle plus de cent mille hommes aux
frontières de la pologne se sont
terminées hier l'otan va de son côté
lancer quatre cent mille hommes sur le
terrain à l'occasion de ces prochaines
manoeuvres d'automne ces images
impressionnantes des manoeuvres
soviétiques ont peut-être influencé le
secrétaire d'état américain aux affaires
étrangères général lane
le général qui est arrivé ce matin à
berlin général est qui aussitôt arrivé à
berlin a prononcé un discours en forme
de véritable réquisitoire à l'égard de
l'union soviétique
quant à son utilisation des armes
chimiques mortels dans le sud est
asiatique aussi bien au cambodge qu'en
afghanistan ou encore au laos
il a appelé également les alliés
occidentaux à se livrer à un peu moins
d'introspection sur eux-mêmes et de
complaisance à l'égard de moscou des
sociétés démocratiques at il dit doivent
à la fois assurer leurs progrès social
et leur défense pendant ce temps des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
protestant contre le réarmement de
l'otan et surtout l'installation d'euros
missiles sur le sol ouest allemand
s'affrontaient très durement avec les
forces de l'ordre
philippe rochon
le général aig au pied du mur de berlin
c'était aujourd'hui le symbole de la
nouvelle amérique de ronald reagan au
coeur d'une ville coupée en deux qui
marque depuis 33 ans la lutte entre le
monde occidental et le bloc soviétique
on attendait un discours dur et ferme le
secrétaire d'état américain ne s'est pas
dérobé dénonçant d'abord ce qu'il
appelle pour le danger soviétique
contrôle des armements at il dit ne peut
se faire dans le vide
l'otan doit moderniser ses forces
nucléaires les soviétiques occupe
toujours l'afghanistan l'urss est engagé
dans un énorme effort militaire qui
dépasse ses besoins réels de défense
moscou utilise aussi des armes chimiques
il faut défendre la démocratie l'avenir
de l'occident est en jeu des filles aux
soviétiques mais aussi un avertissement
aux européens à cette volonté de
poursuivre la course aux armements au
problème des euromissiles au problème de
la bombe à neutrons
plusieurs mouvements ont répondu au
général aig en faisant descendre leurs
militants dans la rue cinquante mille
personnes des jeunes pour la plupart ont
dénoncé dans leurs slogans
la politique de réarmement de l'actuelle
administration américaine et gaber lundi
sept îles c'est une provocation
il faut arrêter la politique de
réarmement démentiel de l'otan bagarre
police une centaine d'arrestations
berlin n'oubliera pas le passage du
général d'aig qui n'a duré que quelques
heures et qui montre incontestablement
que les états unis ce soir ont durci le
ton à l'égard de moscou
et justement moscou ne s'y trompe pas
qui vient de réagir très rapidement par
l'intermédiaire de l'agencé officielle
soviétique tu as qui vient de qualifier
les propos du général tech tenus à
l'égard de l'union soviétique de propos
de calomnies ajoutons à cela pour être
vraiment complet essayons de savoir plus
tôt qui sont ces manifestants hostiles
aux états unis et surtout à
l'installation de fusées américaines sur
le sol de la semaine fédérale une
enquête de michel meyer au pied du reich
tac le symbole de l'ex-allemagne
impérial il est désormais des musiques
qui détonne dans un décor aussi austère
berlin-ouest plus que jamais vu le signe
d'une quête permanente et
antiautoritaires vers un autre type de
société une alternative au monde actuel
marginaux certes mais omniprésent les
quelques cent mille alternative de
berlin sont aussi des adversaires
résolus de la course aux armements et
les adeptes d'un pacifisme qui les rend
étrangement plus hostiles à l'amérique
cas l'union soviétique
devons nous nous ne voulons pas mourir
pour défendre des intérêts américains
en fait l'europe n'est tout simplement
pas défendable et les américains doivent
comprendre qu'ils ne peuvent utiliser
notre territoire pour une guerre
nucléaire d'ailleurs impraticable voici
les ce que 10 à berlin que les leaders
pas sorti en août les arthrites amfar
nick marc pays
mais pour l'instant la présence
militaire américaine et allié à berlin
et l'irremplaçable garantie de la
liberté de la ville et de son
appartenance au monde occidental
cet état de fait est largement acceptée
par ce que l'on appelle ici la majorité
silencieuse
il reste que la nouvelle politique de
force des états unis dérange jusqu'au
sein du parti social-démocrate au
pouvoir à bonn et soulève des allergies
qui rappelle celle de l'époque de la
guerre du vietnam
en réalité en réarmant les américains ne
compense pas un désavantage par rapport
à l'est nous dit-on ici mais il met en
place un nouveau système d'armes
il n'y a pas à linverse et du côté
soviétique d'une nouvelle catégorie
d'armes
et c'est la différence partant de telles
positions il a donc était tout naturel
que des jeunes amis politiques de vie
libre en telus helmut schmidt se
solidarise avec les soixante mille
manifestants pacifistes et anti
américains d'aujourd'hui cela dans une
protestation qui dure ici à berlin et
qui est toujours aux limites de
l'affrontement violent
en fait on a renoué aujourd'hui avec une
hostilité anti américaines qui ne recule
devant aucun acte symbolique
oui ajoutons à cela pour être vraiment
complet que les états unis ont décidé de
retarder de quatre mois à l'installation
des euromissiles sur le sol de
l'allemagne fédérale car le chancelier
schmitt ne veux pas être le seul
entreposer ses fusées sur son territoire
le chancelier schmitt actuellement
baisse de popularité d'ailleurs dans le
pignon ouest allemande
le dernier sondage en date donnent 36 %
seulement des intentions de vote à son
parti le parti social-démocrate contre
50% aux chrétiens démocrates dans
l'opposition
enfin encore à l'occasion dû voyage de
monsieur aig 3 engins incendiaires ont
été lancés contre la demeure du consul
des états unis à francfort heureusement
sans faire de victimes ni de dégâts
importants
un mort 28 blessés c'est le bilan
définitif de l'attentât à la bombe dont
a été victime un groupe de terroristes
italiens dans la vieille ville de
jérusalem le gouvernement israélien
aussitôt réuni à décider des mesures de
sécurité accrues pour les touristes en
visite dans les lieux saints de l'état
hébreu et justement ces lieux saints
sont l'objet d'une grave polémique en
israël à propos de fouilles
archéologiques entreprises sous le
temple de salomon et à proximité de la
mosquée al aqsa deux lieux saints sacrés
du judaïsme et de la religion musulmane
ces fouilles ont donc pour résultat de
provoquer à la fois la colère des ultra
orthodoxes juifs qui parle de
profanation et des gardiens d'un mosquée
un reportage de notre correspondant en
israël
charles enderlin les mosquées demain
réel
axa le mur des lamentations dernier
vestige du temple d'hérode
symbiose fragile du premier lieu saint
du judaïsme avec le troisième de l'islam
un équilibre précaire menacé par le
tunnel qui s'insinue sous les mosquées
au fond de ce couloir et que les rabbins
ont déblayé à la recherche d'un trésor
découvrir
de moïse avec l'étape de leur a offerte
au peuple d'israël sur le monde du sinaï
le candélabre d'or etc
il ya eu des grèves des manifestations
de musulmans le gouvernement ne nous a
pas permis de continuer il a fallu
murray le tunnel est demandé c'est un
crime que de noms que nous avons empêché
d'essayer de les découvrir la mosquée
fait partie du temple et le taux grec à
nous un peu le mont du temple
la montant du temps tu quelqu'un comme
ça dit il c'est pas de la mosquée omar
du temple des dub et avic d'âge de
tombes d'israël le saint des saints
les projets des rabbins suscite
l'inquiétude des responsables musulmans
cette laiterie ben parce que c'est notre
masque c'est les mosquées seulement les
espoirs des rabbins sont sans fondement
disent les scientifiques à quelques
centaines de mètres des mosquées les
archéologues ont choisi la cité pour
wade vide pour effectuer des fouilles
le rabbinat affirme qu'un cimetière juif
existait à cet endroit et qu'il y as
profanation de tombes les ultra
orthodoxes manifestent pour exiger
l'arrêt immédiat des partis religieux
menacent de faire éclater la coalition
gouvernementale
la faire dépouiller
nationale c'est la question du caractère
même de l'établissement
c'est une question de la séparation
d'état et de religion dans ce climat où
nous vivons si la majorité de la
population ne s'exprime pas et sur ces
sujets il y à une vérité danger
d'échanger tous les caractères de ces
pays et de les rendre dans un pays
théocratique les extrémistes religieux
est ce que vous croyez qu'on puisse
arriver à une crise gouvernementale à
cause de ces quelques pierres et de ses
poteries on est en train de fouiller
ce n'est pas une question de quelques
pierres cette question de principe d'un
crise gouvernementale peut développer
pour l'instant la haute cour de justice
permet la poursuite des fouilles à la
grande satisfaction des archéologues le
nombre de volontaires augmente ce qui
montre que nous jouissons d'un soutien
important dans les positions d'israël
nous sommes dues tant que d'autres ne
s'avoue pas vaincue pour que celle ci
en bref encore les iraniens éliront un
président de la république le 2 octobre
prochain
l'ancien président rajaï ils ont été
tués avec son premier ministre à la fin
du mois d'août dernier le président
tchadien monsieur goukouni wahda et
repousse une nouvelle fois la
proposition de fusion avec la libye
proposée il ya moins d'une quinzaine de
jours par le colonel kadhafi
le correspondant du journal le monde au
caire jean-pierre péroncel hugoz aux a
été expulsé aujourd'hui après d'autres
journalistes d'ailleurs il est accusé de
manque d'objectivité et cela dans tous
les domaines
le pape jean paul ii a confirmé
aujourd'hui qu'il publierait mardi
prochain une encyclique sur le monde du
travail un texte particulièrement
important dans le contexte économique
actuel
enfin l'union soviétique je n'oubliais
tout à l'heure à propos des événements
de berlin aurait procédé à une explosion
nucléaire c'est du moins ce qu'affirme
un observatoire météo hollandais qui
considère cette explosion comme la plus
importante enregistrée cette année le
débat sur la peine de mort à l'assemblée
nationale constituera l'un des grands
moments politiques de cette semaine qui
vient sera depuis le 17 juin 1791 date à
laquelle l'assemblée constituante décida
de maintenir cette sentence la 83e fois
que les élus du peuple débattront de ce
problème cette fois-ci mathématiquement
du moins la majorité socialiste devrait
voter l'abolition de la peine capitale
en prélude de ce débat demain soir sur
antenne 2 à 20h30 paul lefèvre et la
rédaction d'antenne 2 présenteront une
émission spécialisation se présente de
la face
suivante durant son septennat et suivant
la latitude du général de gaulle et de
monsieur georges pompidou le sud jusqu'à
destin qui se prononçaient
personnellement contre la peine de mort
avait laissé passer la justice comme on
dit une fois le 28 juillet 76
l'exécution de christian ranucci mme
c'est une petite fille pour répondre en
quelque sorte au sentiment d'insécurité
que le président garde des sceaux
monsieur alain peyrefitte qualifiait de
profonds dans la société française la
majorité parlementaire d'une part les
sondages d'autre part conforter cette
position s'était pas qu'en début de
l'année
63% des français se déclaraient
favorables au maintien qu'à peine de
mort au cours de la campagne électorale
françois mitterrand le 16 mars 1980 sur
cette même antenne d'ailleurs déclaré
dans ma conscience profonde
je suis contre la peine de mort quatre
jours après son élection à la présidence
françois mitterrand commuée en réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité la condamnation
à mort de philip morris la majorité
parlementaire actuelle plus une
trentaine de députés de l'opposition
sont pour l'abolition l'assemblée
nationale
c'est la situation au sénat la majorité
semble être plutôt favorable pour le
maintien de la peine de mort le débat
doit durer jusqu'à la fin du mois de
lectures successives par assemblée
l'abolition de la peine de mort est une
question de fond une question de société
c'est la raison pour laquelle antenne 2
a décidé d'y consacrer son premier grand
magazine de rentrée lundi soir demain à
20h30 à faire vous concernant la peine
de mort dans l'affrontement des passions
et des chiffres nous tenterons de
découvrir la mesure un sondage sur le
gouvernement monsieur mauroy les cadres
jugent les 100 jours du gouvernement de
monsieur mauroy cela c'est un sondage
réalisé par le cides pour le compte du
quotidien de paris publié demain matin
alors les cadres sont en majorité 50%
des favorable aux nationalisations 42% y
sont favorables 800 opinion à propos du
gel du programme nucléaire il est
désapprouvée par 56% des personnes
interrogées 41 % étant favorable par
contre 71 % des cadres sont pour l'impôt
sur la fortune
et seulement 24% contre monsieur pierre
devise est le patron du sac notre
confrère le journal du dimanche
aujourd'hui réaffirme qu'il n'a rien à
voir avec la tuerie d'auriol que l'on
veut faire un procès politique à son
organisation
le sac est enfin qu'il met tous ses
hommes à la disposition de la nouvelle
opposition ce qui était déjà le cas
lorsqu'il s'agissait de la majorite'
sondages encore sofres sur le cancer
pour le magazine vivre 79% des personnes
interrogées sont d'accord pour que le
médecin leur dise la vérité
44% des personnes interrogées avouent
qu'elles ont déjà pensé avoir un cancer
c'est dire que pratiquement un français
sur deux pense qu'il a pensé à cette
maladie ce qui prouve bien que cette
maladie est bien dans tous les esprits
suite de la rentrée scolaire cette
semaine une rentrée dont on a déjà
beaucoup parlé à propos de la hausse des
prix des fournitures ses fournitures qui
représente un chiffre d'affaires
important pour l'industrie française
comme le prouve cette enquête de
christian marie monnet
le papier constitue la trame le fil
conducteur de l'activité scolaire car la
rentrée des élèves est un phénomène
économie et papeterie l'édition scolaire
représente un chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 5 milliards de francs
l'industrie du papier c'est plus de 5
millions de tonnes pour l'année 80 et
30000 salariés
le marché de l'édition scolaire c'est un
chiffre d'affaires de quelque 700
millions de francs pour l'année 1980 et
cette année 55 millions de livres
sortent des imprimeries donc plus de
3500 titre nouveau les responsables de
l'édition retourne donc en classe pour
les connaître à les faire connaître
en raison de la gratuité des livres dans
le premier cycle c'est à dire de la
classe de 6e à la 3e
de la pression de l'état et prix des
livres suivi sensiblement la hausse
générale des prix
l'édition scolaire historiquement depuis
dix ans peut se flatter
et c'est prouvé constatée par l'insee
régulièrement et encore la semaine
dernière par l'association des familles
d'avoir toujours été en dessous de la
hausse des prix en 1981 un peu plus de
12 % d'augmentation
et pour cette année nous serons
plusieurs points en dessous la hausse
des prix
du côté des papiers dont le chiffre
d'affaires frôle les 4 milliards de
francs 25 mille pme et 6500 points de
vente
on se défend de pratiquer des hausses
excessives avec près de 20 mille
articles différents en vente chez votre
papier et dérapages existent mais une
certaine autodiscipline est pratiqué par
la majorité des commerçants ils se
sentent sous haute surveillance
ils ont donc pris leurs précautions et
ont fait leur propre enquête
nous avons fait des constats d'huissiers
qui prouve dans tout les agents de
france que les articles pour la rentrée
scolaire nous ont augmenté de 10 minimum
15 en moyenne jusqu'à 22% je me répète
sur les sur tout ce qui est à base de
papier certes la marge des grands
magasins est inférieur de un à deux
points à celle des détaillants
le petit commerçant est à votre
disposition en toute l'année enfin vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'aller j'ai trop
rapidement votre porte monnaie en
achetant tout à la rentrée est allé donc
vos dépenses au cours de l'année
en bref encore une nouvelle associations
de rapatriés d'algérie leur cour
considère comme inacceptable le choix du
19 mars pour commémorer la fin de la
guerre d'algérie rappelons que pour
monsieur laurin le ministre des anciens
combattants il ne s'agit pas de faire de
cette date qui marque la signature des
accords d'evian une fête nationale mais
une journée de commémoration des
victimes de ce conflit
le tiercé cet après midi à longchamp
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 2 le 6
et le 13 ses chevaux avaient été données
par pierrette brès dans ses pronostics
au pire aide les rapports de ce tiercé
dans l'ordre 377 francs 50 veut pas dire
qu'elles vous ait fait gagner beaucoup
d'argent dans un ordre différent 75
francs 50 centimes toujours pour 5
alain prost et renault vainqueur du
grand prix de formule 1 de monza en
italie troisième victoire dans un grand
prix pour alain paule prost depuis le
début de cette année le commentaire d'un
rib odile
c'est une renault et pour la quatrième
fois celle de rené arnoux qui occupe la
pole position aux côtés de ruth main de
van projeté la fidh s'est du reste alain
prost qui prend le meilleur départ
devant rené arnoux reitman 0
autrement dit à part m 110 kg est
enfermé dans le peloton tous les favoris
il sent qu'elle a du monde sont dans le
groupe de tête y compris les outsider
alain prost domaine largement de gamins
jones quand vers la mi-course la mclaren
de john watson sort un peu large
déséquilibre et la voiture de
l'irlandais traversé la piste et va
percuter de plein fouet par l'arrière le
rail de sécurité
dans le choc la voiture est coupée en
deux à la hauteur du pilote
heureusement sans dommages pour watson
le moteur et où l'autre arrière traverse
la piste une nouvelle fois ce qui
provoquera par ailleurs l'élimination de
cheever qui évite le tout en se frottant
le long du rail largement en tête alain
prost qui a mené de bout en bout et plus
ou moins longuement tous les grands prix
depuis silverstone
alain prost enlève ainsi son troisième
grand prix de la saison après dijon est
morte devant alan jones brightman d
angers 10 ironie et nelson piquet est
oui au classement des coureurs pour le
championnat du monde carlos trautmann
est toujours en tête devant nelson
piquet tu es le français donc à l'impôt
tennis coupe davis à paris la france
mène deux victoires à une devant le
japon noah et christian roger vasselin
ont remporté le double cet après midi et
puis bien sûr ce soir dans le dernier
journal peut être le résultat de la
finale entre borg et mcenroe à flushing
meadow record du monde encore du 5000
mètres battue en norvège par le kenyan
henry renault qui a battu son propre
record pour terminer la fête de
l'humanité je le disais tout à l'heure
une manifestation à la fois culturelle
et politique la culture étaient
présentes cette année avec l'exposition
du centenaire de pablo picasso picasso à
travers sa peinture mais aussi la poésie
et le spectacle un reportage de georges
bigot
picasso présent à la fête de l'humanité
ce n'est pas la première fois on se
souvient que le peintre a dit rao parti
communiste en 1944 mais pour le
centenaire de sa naissance
plusieurs expositions du sont consacrés
et particulièrement celle des gravures
dans laquelle on entre comme dans un
labyrinthe
picasso graveur est assez méconnue il a
pourtant excellé dans cet art qu'il a
pratiqué toute sa vie en marge de la
peinture de la sculpture ou de la
céramique
qu'il s'agisse d'eaux-fortes de taille
douce de lithographie ou de linogravure
on retrouve ses thèmes favoris
le minotaure le corps humain les visages
la lumière les bacchanales la
tauromachie ou les étreintes
sa technique est classique comparable à
celle des durait rembrandt ou daumier ce
qui n'est pas classique c'est la
richesse d'invention dans le trait dans
la traduction des volumes et kasso
demeure l'homme qui aggravait le plus de
planches au monde et jean-pierre
jouffroy et gérard chanteloup qui ont
établi cet itinéraire propose au regard
une fête dont la qualité et la rigueur
sont irréprochables
les saltimbanques que ceux de la période
bleue
les voici sur la grande scène de la
courneuve là c'est un autre hommage à
picasso sous forme de revue ou de grands
bals et ils marquent les étapes de
l'évolution du peintre ici l'influencent
de l'art [ __ ]
le fameux est scandaleux ballet parade
d'erik satie que picasso avait décoré et
costumés à sa manière
à présent les musiciens qui peut plaire
en permanence les toiles cubistes des
années folles pendant deux heures
s'anime ainsi sur fond de tableau ou
deux photos géantes une existence est
une oeuvre qui peuvent se dansent et se
chanter car elle était l'expression même
de la vie
pour terminer dans un tout autre genre
celui ci initiative originale mais a
signalé des gendarmes de l'indre et
loire qui ces dernières semaines au lieu
de verbalisé les excès de vitesse arrête
les automobilistes et leur montre des
photographies d'accident grave due
justement une vitesse excessive et qui
sont responsables selon les statistiques
de 30% des accidents de la route
la météo pour conclure aussi les
prévisions pour demain ça se gâte vous
me direz que c'est la saison qui veut ça
dès le matin un temps très nuageux avec
des pluies va envahir d'ouest en est une
partie du pays située au nord de la
ligne bordeaux-grenoble avant les pluies
le temps sera brumeux et frais le matin
puis le ciel sera très nuageux dans la
moitié nord de la france et ensoleillé
dans le sud-ouest sur la provence et la
corse de temps sera nuageux le matin
mais s'améliorera par la suite les
orages affecteront la corse et cela dans
la soirée pour le dernier journal ce
sera la sphère de serge me serait aux
alentours de 23 heures 25 demain
l'invité d'antenne 2010 sera madame
nicole questiaux qui est ministre de la
solidarité nationale
pour ma part il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 bonsoir